foreign
[Music]
and welcome to another end game video
I'm recording this from the beautiful
city of Toronto Canada where I will be
covering the chess.com Global Chess
Championship
something I'm incredibly excited about
and for this reason as you've probably
already noticed uh the video and mainly
the audio quality is not what it usually
is that's because I don't have any of my
regular streaming and recording
equipment I'm just doing this straight
up for my laptop and originally I wasn't
planning to do any content while in
Toronto but I just passed the car
Nakamura in the lobby of the hotel I
feel so motivated you know staying in a
new and really cool City and a cool
hotel and you know I'm just in the mood
to you know to do some chess especially
because I've assembled all of the
material already for this next end game
video so uh first and foremost I ask for
your understanding and your forgiveness
hopefully the audio will be bearable I'm
trying to talk a little bit more quietly
to avoid triggering any any peaking uh
or any weird noises so so this is a
particularly exciting video because in
this and the following video you will
have the opportunity to put everything
that you have learned over the past five
pawn and game videos to the test you
will have the opportunity to solve 10
really cool exercises that cover
virtually all of the concepts and themes
and ideas that we have talked through
over the past few videos whether it's
opposition or zugz Wang or understanding
and using past pawns playing against
them upon breakthroughs literally
everything that we have covered I have
tried to choose 10 examples that help
you review those Concepts but also to
Nuance your understanding of them and
see how they are applied by strong
players in the wild so before we jump in
a couple of words on how I recommend
that you approach this in the following
video in the description there will be
two PGN files the first will contain the
puzzles themselves and the second will
contain the puzzles Plus the solutions
five at a time
so if you sort of want to do this like a
professional then I would suggest that
you download the file containing the
puzzles you try to solve them on your
own you spend as long as you you want
there's no you know recommended time
limits as long as you need to do your
very best
try to propose solutions for each of
them do what you can and then watch this
video carefully or I will go through
each of these positions in great detail
I will not only walk you through the
solution itself but also try to help you
understand how a deep knowledge of the
concepts that we have gone over in the
last couple of videos
should have helped you arrive at the
solution
um so if you watch that you can also
download the file containing the
solutions uh and I have tried to be as
detailed as possible in that file in
case you know you don't want to watch
the video you want a tldr or you want
something that can help you review
obviously you're under no obligation to
treat this as a test if you just want to
chill and watch this video and you don't
want to do any solving that is perfectly
fine that is totally acceptable and I
hope that this video can also function
as kind of a standalone instructional
overview of all of these Concepts and so
whether you have already downloaded the
puzzle file and you have taken a stab at
these five puzzles or whether as again
modder says or just along for the ride
let's jump into these positions let's
talk all about them and let's get this
thing underway okay so I'm gonna
switch scenes here
okay
and I'm also going to enable a little
uh part of a Word document that will
hopefully contain
hopefully contain uh some useful
information that you can rely on and use
that you can rely on and use as I'm
explaining the solutions there we go and
I'm going to do what I usually do when
we transition from one puzzle to the
next I'm going to
switch that text box on the bottom so
that text box just contains a sort of
overarching themes of each exercise as
well as a couple of tips that stem from
the correct solution it's really just
for reference it's not exhaustive but
hopefully that helps you out a little
bit so uh before we actually jump in I
will say that these exercises and
positions uh were supposed to be
challenging if you tried your best and
you're saying to yourself man I I
couldn't solve any of them I feel like I
haven't learned any of these Concepts
properly don't feel that way you know
don't feel that not getting the
Solutions in their entirety means that
you have not appreciated the concepts or
you've not listened attentively to the
previous videos these are meant to be
incredibly challenging and some of them
very strong players did not find the
correct solution in full or even in part
and so this is really meant uh not just
as a kind of rote exercise where you
just kind of parrot the concepts you
know that's kind of boring this is also
met as I said at the start to really
Nuance your understanding to help you
deepen your conception of these Concepts
and the way that they play a role in
especially complicated and juicy Pawn
end games and above all else I hope you
actually enjoy these examples I hope
that you're able to appreciate the
beauty in them because at the end of the
day why are we doing this if it's not
out of an appreciation for how beautiful
end games especially Pawn end games can
be okay
and finally we're ready so in our first
example
uh White is none other than the world
champion Jose Raul capablanca and he is
playing a cyborg game a simultaneous
exhibition game against a totally
unknown player and this totally unknown
player Tuckerman has basically been neck
and neck the entire game against
capoblock it was a close game and they
reached the position that's on the board
in front of you with black to move now
you might first Wonder okay is this some
sort of a typo is this the position I
intended to give because there are Rooks
on the board and I'm supposed to be
helping you review pod endings well it's
not quite a typo I did intend to give
this position because the first thing
that you should notice after looking at
the board for a couple of seconds is
that the white king and the white Rook
are aligned on the same rank
and with the move Rook V6 black can
actually Force the Rooks off of the
board leading to a very exciting
Pawn race and an incredible long series
of forced moves so the first move is
Rook B6 and just jumping ahead a little
bit when you have a rook on game and you
have the possibility to exchange Rooks
you should always start by calculating
or at least trying to calculate the pawn
end game because as a Rule Pawn end
games are more forcing and they are
easier to calculate than Rook end game
so it's worth starting by assessing the
liquidation the transformation into the
pawn end game now Rook V6 forces white
to take there's simply no other move up
otherwise white loses The Rook so Kappa
Blanca captures on B6 and black proceeds
by recapturing now we have a traditional
Pawn race clearly white cannot stop the
C Pawn so white has to push his only
past Pawn that has a direct path to
promotion and we just get a No Frills
regular Pawn race hopefully you were
able to calculate up to this point C3 E6
C2 E7 and if you feel hazy on how to
assess Pawn races then this is where you
might want to re-watch that video on
Pawn races that contain the five rules
that are supposed to help you evaluate
them one of the rules
says that just because both sides
promote to a queen at the same time
let's say black promotes and then white
promotes it doesn't automatically mean
that the game just ends in a draw and
you absolutely have to check whether you
can win your opponent's Queen often via
a skewer will actually see an example of
that later on but the other thing that
people often forget to check for is
whether the Queens can be exchanged
which once again gets the game into a
pawn end game and then that resulting
Pawn on game it sometimes just so
happens that your opponent's king is
going to be poorly placed in for example
you can create another passed on while
your opponent has exhausted that ability
and kudos to you if you didn't stop
calculating here and just assume that
the position was a draw
another round of Kudos if you didn't
fall for the temptation to give a check
on B2 and say hey let me win this Pawn
on A2 well the problem with that move is
that white can cover with the queen if
you take on Haiti you actually get
checkmated after Queen E7 and queen G7
and queen G5
but what Tuckerman was able to spot is
that the white king and the White Queen
are on adjacent files and the white king
is also confined by its counterpart it
can't really go anywhere on the G file
and there is a way for black to force
the exchange of Queens it starts with
queen F4 check driving the king onto the
e-file does it matter where it goes and
it also doesn't matter where on the
e-file The Black Queen jumps to for
example Queen E4 check in the game black
played Queen E5 chuck coppleblanca had
to step aside and after the queen trade
we get a very interesting situation
black has a two on one on the queen side
and White's King could not possibly be
in a worse place is as far away from the
pawns as possible in the meantime
Black's King fully contains white spawn
and yet another round of Kudos too if
you were successfully able to determine
that black
is able to promote to another queen on
the queen side White's king is not fast
enough the way you do it is you apply
the PPP rule you push the perspective
passer the perspective passer is the
beep on this is more accurate than
playing A4 here like in deep freeze the
pawns with A3 black still wins via a
breakthrough but it's good good form to
play B5 Kappa Blanca brushes his King
back desperately but after B4 King C6 A4
black wins this tempo for Tempo King B5
B3 and at least one of Black's pawns is
going to promote to a queen shockingly
capablanca played played on for like
actually for 10 moves I mean he must
have been upset this is a simul game
um but what amazing calculational effort
by his unknown opponent and
unsurprisingly Tuckerman was able to
convert uh the full extra Queen and so
to summarize this first example first
and foremost consider Le liquidation
consider the exchange over Rooks if you
have a rook end game then that
incredibly important rule of Pawn races
if both sides promote simultaneously you
can't stop calculating you have to
consider whether you can win your
opponent's queen or whether you can
exchange the queens and then in the
resulting position let's say promote to
another queen which is exactly what
happens here
okay on we go to our second second
example and our second example is
another old game it's a game of Akiba
Rubenstein who made an appearance in the
previous video he's facing off against
Paul Leonard who is very very strong
player this game was played I think in
the early 1900s and um let me
change up the little text box here
okay do what I usually do super high
tech I know
all right there we go
okay so it is white to play and it
shouldn't take you too long to determine
that white is the one playing for a win
how do I know that well White's King is
just a lot more active right it's
further Advanced down the board
and another thing that you might notice
is that it's a weird situation where
both sides are kind of deep freezing the
other right whites deep freezing Black's
Pawn majority with this Pawn up before
the classic deep freeze and in a way
black is also deep freezing
a white spawn majority like white can't
easily create a past Pawn on the king
side so it would be very forgivable to
assume that this game should just end in
a draw because neither side can make
progress but that's not true because
White's King is in such a better place
as opposed to its counterpart so the
first thing that should come to mind for
you is well why don't we just take a
dive uh to take a dive or drive however
you want to put it let's go to the queen
side let's eliminate Black's pawns and
then let's promote our b-pawn and so the
move King D6 is indeed very tempting but
here you have to calculate the pawn race
black will do exactly the same thing on
the king side and Black's King is
actually very well positioned to quickly
uh and securely eliminate White's pawns
Paving the way for uh the path of this
h-man and if you go down the Slime King
C6 King G5 this there's no art to this
you just have to brute force your way
down these Pawn races King takes G4 King
takes A6 now important rule do not
capture unnecessary pawns it turns out
that you could take either Pawn with
black but really the clinical move is
King takes H5 white takes on B5 black
steps away with his King white does
exactly the same and as you can
determine pretty easily both sides
promote at the same time and you as a
student of the Pod end game would
quickly check to see whether white
doesn't have any skewers
he doesn't there's absolutely nothing
and in fact it is white uh who is kind
of suffering here because White's
probably going to lose that F Pawn and
could potentially uh even risk losing
the game
so well that's kind of disappointing the
direct Brute Force attempted upon race
doesn't result in success and this is
where you would also be forgiven for
just assuming that White's King
therefore has to just kind of step back
but let's not forget a very important
technique from our video on advanced
concepts in Pawn end games and I called
this moving your opponent's pawns and
what that referred to is a sacrifice a
strategic sacrifice that is intended to
change the pawn structure in a way that
is favorable to you now what does it
mean to change why would a change in pod
structure be favorable to you well there
could be a lot of reasons right it could
have to do with blazing a path for your
king but one of the most legitimate
reasons for sacrificing is to extend the
time that it takes for your opponent to
create a past plan so if you're
anticipating a pawn race a very
well-timed sacrifice could force your
opponent to spend that one extra Tempo
uh to take all of your pawns and as you
guys know by now one extra Tempo is
often the difference between life and
death in a pawn race now what is the the
path that the black king can take to
capture White's pawns well the only path
is through F6 and G5 and so the
brilliant correct first move is to
advance the pawn to F6 forcing black
sheep on onto F6 and blocking the path
of Black's King but that's not all
because here the Temptation Of course is
to play King D6 you might also notice
that there is what seems to be the
exactly equivalent move can D5 both of
these moves seem to produce exactly the
same effect but
you cannot forget as you see in the text
box that just because you are deep
freezing your opponent's Pawns
you cannot assume that there doesn't
exist upon break upon breakthrough can
break through a deep freeze and that's
precisely what happens if you play the
sloppy move King D6 here black can push
A5 breaking through the deep freeze
after ba5b4 again both pawns promote
simultaneously and it's a dead drop if
you want A8 P1 Queen
white is a series of meeting with checks
but that's about it uh black easily
Saves the Game incidentally incidentally
black also has the move F5 here leading
to a pawn race on the other side of the
board that is also a draw so it is
crucial to play King D5 and only King D5
the way that this works is that A5 is
clearly uh no longer effective because
after B4 white just stops the pawn with
his King
and if black tries to strike at the
other side of if black plays F5 and
after gf5 King F6 you want to apply
another rule of Pawn races this is the
final rule which says that you don't
always have to participate in a pawn
race you're not signing a contract and
you don't have to go King C6 here you
drop the king back to E4 you already
have a pass Pawn that's all you need and
uh you win the game in very Elementary
fashion just by using Pawn assisted
opposition to push the black king all
the way to the back and this is a great
uh time to apply a concept that we also
talked through in the advanced uh
Concepts in in Pawn end games video
where you can play King G6 and win the
pawn but the easiest method is is again
to stalemate the black king but you're
not really stalemating black because
black still has A5 and here
here after a7b2 white promotes to a
queen and simultaneously delivers
Checkmate and that is the brilliant win
which Akiba Rubenstein actually missed
in the game he ended up dropping his
King back in resignation literally in
resignation but this is a sign that he
doesn't know what to do he did have one
more trick up his sleeve though and Paul
Leonard really dropped the ball here he
made a series of terrible moves starting
with King F6 uh the easiest way to draw
would have been to actually drop the
king back to EA and the idea is that if
white tries to break through with G5
after hg5 King takes G5 now the king
returns back to F7 and white is simply
in zuk's Von why it has to drop the king
back to G4 F6 is no longer effective H6
actually loses the game after King F6
the white king gets shouldered uh so
this just ends the discussion and if
white plays King E5 we remember
corresponding squares black steps into
opposition and the Kings just start
dancing around the board white cannot
make any progress I won't delve into to
how the game continued you can find that
in the solutions PGN Leonard played at
King F6 now Rubenstein played G5 check
it's still a draw if black steps away to
the right Square Leonard didn't do that
and he ended up losing a queen end game
but the takeaway from this game is that
you can use the concept of sacrificing
your own PODS moving your opponent's
Pawns in order to set yourself up
successfully for a pawn race okay on we
go to the next example let's flip the
board
nope it's not jump with the gun here let
me rewind back to the initial position
and as per usual I'm going to change the
text box here
to reflect the third position
all right I think this is
kind of small let's make that a little
bit bigger there we go
and let's get back to
the recording
all right time for a sip of coffee I
suggest you do the same these end games
are grueling you can see we're only two
games in and uh we've already talked
through like a wide range of Concepts
hope you've enjoyed the examples thus
far we're going to fast forward about
100 years to the 1990s
and what you see in front of you is a
game between two very strong
Grandmasters of Kenny barev who
incidentally now lives in Canada or I'm
currently recording from and black is
Judith poger who needs absolutely no
introduction
so
we are playing Black right you're facing
Judy Pogo and you're trying to win this
end game as per usual it's important to
start with observations right rather
than just starting by calculating random
lines oftentimes if the thought end game
is complex enough you just you need to
get like your bearings you need to get a
sense of what's going on on the board so
What observations can we make well the
first thing that jumps out to me is the
fact that white has a outside passer on
A4 you might remember that an outside
passer is just a pass bond that is as
far away from all of the other pods as
possible Right most of the pawns are on
the king side this Pawn is on the a file
a pass Pawn is generally speaking a
great asset and what makes it an even
greater asset is if it is protected by
another Pawn a protected outside pass
Pawn is often a massive trump card
in pod end games in it often wins you
the game and this pod 94 is indeed a
protected outside passer white can play
B3 on demand uh to to protect that but
what it does is it greatly limits the
scope of Black's King Black's King is
kind of on a leash in the sense that it
can move uh somewhat to the king side
and then return to stop the a-pawn but
it can't move too far if it moves to the
f-file then white is just going to start
pushing uh his his a pawn and the King
will not be able to stop it in time
looking at the king side the situation
also does not appear encouraging for
black because the epon is deep freezing
blacks enf pawns and although it does
have damaged ah bonds there kind of
doing the job and they're holding back
blacks uh ostensibly healthier uh Pawn
formation as well
but these observations don't tell the
whole story because we have to notice
one more thing there's a Pawn on E5 and
that pawn is isolated it is weak and it
cannot be defended either by upon or by
a king and so the only logical way for
black to start in this position is to
shift the king up to T5
attempting continuation would be to play
C4 in order to try to slice off the a
pawn from its cousin on B2 the problem
is that this creates too big of a
weakness on C4 and whites King smelling
blood would move to D2 and then it would
move whatever you do it would move to C3
and black is just in zuzong Black has to
slide her King over white plays A5 and
here the easiest way to win is via a
method that we have discussed many times
if you have a past Pawn of one side of
the board you force your opponent's king
to distract uh to distract Itself by
taking that pawn in the meantime you go
around and you take all of the pawns on
the other side of the board you don't
need to push the B Pawn you can just
leave it on B2 you can leave it as far
away as possible from Black's King and
just go King C5 King D6 and and King E7
you win
so C4 doesn't work we have to start with
King D5 now obviously barev is not just
going to let Polgar capture the plot on
E5 if white plays a move like P3 then
black captures on E5 and at this point
black already gets connected passers on
the king side and black winds pretty
easily
um so of course bereave in this position
automatically plays the move A5 which
seems to be part of his sweat he's
pushing his passer and what's important
is that King takes E5 now fails to A6
Black's king is not in time by a Tempo
to stop the pawn
but that's exactly the point once the
pawn reaches A5 it can no longer be
protected by the b-pawn so the move King
D5 essentially does what C4 does except
it doesn't create an additional Pawn
weakness and now comes the sort of first
brilliant part of polgar's idea she
moves her King back to C6 once again you
can consider this moving your opponent's
pawns or I would refer to it as inducing
a weakness you have forced the a pawn
forward and as you hopefully know by now
pushing pawns does not mean good right
there those are not synonyms pushing
your pawns and pawning games can
actually be precisely what leads to your
downfall and now black is poised to play
King B5 win the pawn on A5 and then
convert the end game but that's still
not the end of the story and you would
be totally forgiven for assuming that
this is already where the game is
supposed to end if Guinea barev comes up
with a devilish defensive concept Place
King D3 poker plays King B5
now he plays the move B3
you can take say five King C4 okay King
drops back to B6 to defend C5 this is
all forced and now baraf slides his King
back to D3
and he says guess what
my Pawn E5 is controlling D6 my Pawn B3
is controlling A4 black has no
infiltration squares with her King if
black plays King B5 white plays King C3
and black is in zuksvong remember we
have to assess who has how many waiting
moves and here both sides have zero
weighting moves but that's more
important for black in this case because
that means that black has to slide her
King back from B5 well we can't make
progress that way can we make progress
the other way not really it leads to the
same exact thing white plays King C4
covering the D5 square and Black's King
has no choice but to move back to P6 but
this is where one particular Troublesome
concept comes into play
without applying this concept you cannot
win this position and that is the
concept of triangulation and there's a
couple of related ideas that you have to
fully understand in order to even come
up with the idea of triangulating care
so triangulation is a process by which
you kind of draw a triangle with your
king with the aim of getting a
particular position a particular Target
position with the other side to move now
what position do we want to get with
white to move well you can determine
this by drawing up the corresponding
squares and I remind you that the
corresponding squares are squares where
let's say white skin reaches a square
Black's King has to reach a
corresponding Square in order to avoid
zugspawn so if both sides are sitting on
their corresponding squares the side
whose move it is is in zuzvong so
essentially you want to hit your
corresponding Square after your opponent
hits their corresponding Square so that
might be a bunch of gibberish to you
although hopefully you kind of
understand a little bit more after the
last video what are the corresponding
squares here well there's basically two
sets there's the squares B5 and C3 let's
draw that in green and then there's C6
and C4 so if Black's King reaches B5
White's King wants to step on C3 but not
in the other order
if it was white to move here white would
have to move his King away from C3
allowing Black's King to infiltrate B4
then black would push C4 uh clearing
mowing the lawn by the way and and
clearing a pathway to the E5 pod the
same exact thing goes for the other set
of Correspondence corresponding squares
if black plays King C6 white wants to be
the one to step to C4 so essentially
black one's either this position or this
position but with white to move and this
is where triangulation comes to the
rescue rather than playing King C6 you
step back to C7
white cannot step onto C4 because then
black hits the corresponding Square
second that's what we want white has to
toggle between C3 and D3 waiting until
black gets to C6 but now the
triangulation continues with King B7
again white has no choice but to play
King D3 but Ray by the way resigned in
this position he already knew what was
what was coming but after King D3 we
complete the triangulation with King B6
observe the pattern that black thing has
taken in the last couple of moves it's
gone from B6 to C7
to B7 to B6 and that is just a pure
triangulation maneuver and all of a
sudden white is busted because white has
to step onto one of his corresponding
squares first either you can see four
king C6 and black winds or white has to
play King C3 that's another
corresponding Square black plays King B5
the whole point is that if y tries to
circumvent that with King C2 the pawn on
E5 being weak is what costs white the
game black plays King C6 and reaches D5
in time so triangulation often isn't
possible without these like additional
weaknesses that take away certain
weighting moves from your opponent's
king and this is a case in point the
pawn 25 being weak means that white
always has to keep his King in close
proximity to the C4 uh the C4 square and
it can't step back to C2 Black's King
just has more real estate to maneuver on
and that's what triangulation ultimately
Works barev he resigned after King B7 if
King C4 then King CC 6 if King T3 the 19
C6 but King B6 forcing white to occupy
one of the Mind squares the king slides
up to B5 and after King C2 King B4 can
be two a simple instantiation but still
very much an instance of mowing the lawn
you want to clear the pathway to the
center and so you play the move C4 takes
takes and I don't really have to show
any more black wins the pawn and E5 and
easily converts the two extra pawns so I
already forgot what I wrote in the in
the text box so the theme induces
weaknesses triangulation there there's
obviously more themes than that but
again this is just a good rough outline
to help you contextualize file this away
in your mental Rolodex
um so the tips are you can use your king
to provoke a weakness by forcing your
opponent to unchain their pawns or move
upon forward uh construct the target
positions you're trying to achieve and
whose side to move before triangulation
so what this really means is that you
should be aware of what the
corresponding squares are and you want
to know uh you know whose move you want
it to be in a particular kind of
position
okay hopefully this this helps clear up
triangulation just a little bit all
right again I made the mistake of fast
forwarding through the solution there
but it's time for exercise number four
all right I've been going for about 30
minutes so pretty happy with the timing
thus far I don't want this video to be
too long that's why I'm breaking it up
into two if we did 10 puzzles that would
have just been totally crazy okay let's
make this a little bit bigger
so the next example we talk about
inducing weaknesses once again and we
talk about opposition and I really
really love this example I think this
will really help you understand uh an
important aspect of dealing with Pawn
races and King races this is just a
lovely lovely sequence so
it's two guys named liosh two Hungarian
players but the guy playing Black is a
lot more famous lighter supports you
she's still alive uh one of the leading
Grandmasters in the world in the 50s and
60s his opponent just a experienced
Hungarian master
and uh what's interesting is that
Fortress wrote a book on end games
called 600 end games very like not a
popular book at all but I had it that
was I think the first endgame book that
I worked through with my coach it was
like 600 constructive end game positions
there was no text they were just moves
um and it really ignited you know my
love for endgame so this this is a
little bit of my paying the respects
back to to laish fortish uh considering
one of his lovely end game wins so okay
so we have clearly a situation where
both kings are uh running toward the
opposing set of Pawns and trying to
capture as many of them as possible
so We examined an example like this in
in the last uh in the last video where
we we mentioned that it's important not
to just assume that in such positions uh
the only thing that you can do is walk
your king toward the enemy puns you can
also use your pawns to modify the pawn
structure to create a better situation
for your king so obviously the first
thing that you should calculate is King
E4 what happens if black reaches White's
pawns and it seems like black must be
winning here black is so much faster so
much closer to White's pawns than
White's King but the problem is that
after F5 white has built a pawn chain
and it takes an additional two moves for
black to reach the base of that pawn
chain in the meantime white has two
moves to reach E7 and because the black
spawn structure is so much less sound
and so much weaker it turns out that
white is able to hold the draw after
King D7 sorry king of three KD7 King G3
King G7 King takes H3 nothing else the
black can do
white has to take the correct Bond here
and if you didn't reach this position in
your solution I would encourage you to
pause the video and
try to figure out which Pawn white
should take
now you can consider this a kind of
illustration of charting a course where
you just want to grab a random Pond you
want to actually evaluate both options
and if you do so you will see that King
takes F6 is a grave error because after
King takes G4 you're in zoo you can't
get capture the F7 Pawn without giving
up F5 now the kings are in opposition
and black just runs the h-man up the
board so you want to do it in the
opposite order you want to take F7 first
then after King takes G4 you take F6
simultaneously defending F5 and it's not
hard to calculate that the pawn race
results in a draw King G6 H4 blah blah
blah H2 fa Queen H1 Queen and black is
really the one who gets lucky here
because Queen F5 check almost wins the
queen it just so happens the black has
the G3 square right and then we talked
about these scenarios a lot where the
king is on the G file and the queen is
on the H file you cannot just assume
that these situations are always a draw
okay so let's rewind all the way back
all the way back to the initial position
right we have considered King 14 E3
results in the same sequence
and we have to realize that even though
black spawns are incredibly ruined one
of the interesting properties of pod end
games that doubled pawns are often an
asset the reason is that you can
sacrifice the first of these double
pawns and you still avoid a situation
where you gift your opponent a past Pawn
right normally if you give away a pawn
that's on a file your opponent captures
it they have a now now have a past Pawn
not so when your pawns are doubled and
so you can use that interesting feature
and play the move F6 F5 again this is a
version a form of inducing weaknesses in
White's Pawn structure so what
specifically does this move do well this
invites White
to take on F5 and it shifts White's
pawns to more capturable squares here
after King E4
black is already ready to take both of
these Pawns
if white plays F6 we get a very
interesting sequence King takes F4 King
D7 King F5 King E17 G6 we talked about
this scenario what do we look for in
such a scenario well we look at the
waiting moves which side can exhaust
their waiting moves less and it's not
hard to determine that that side is us
it is black white has only one waiting
move and now black calibrates his
winning moves based on where white spawn
is we play H5 we dislodge the king from
E7 capture F6 and win the game so here
waiting moves come into play now black
white doesn't have to play F6 white can
also directly head for black spawns King
D7 and now black is the same choice that
white had in that other line which Pawn
should black capture well the answer is
F5 If instead black captures F4 then
white draws in relatively Elementary
fashion with King E7
King takes F5 King takes F7 and if black
tries to run up to the H Pawn then white
is just going to draw for example with
King E6
and after kg3 King F5 white reaches the
promised land whatever black does if
black takes and King G5 and King H6
draws and if flag plays H5 a keen
knowledge of theoretical end games is
required here white doubles back to E4
and then locks in the king with King F3
we talked about this scenario in like a
more complicated version this of course
is a very famous draw because black can
make absolutely zero progress progress
Corner pawns are just totally lame in
these kinds of situations so the correct
Pawn to take is actually F5 so and after
King E7 the final critical moment of
this game arises this actually happened
in the game
again if black just merely takes the
pawn in F4 then white recaptures on F7
and it's a draw King G3 may look like it
wins but again white has this trick King
F6
and if black plays King takes H3 white
goes King G5 and doubles back to gh6 and
if black plays H5
then it's very important for white to be
accurate pause the video figure out
where White's King should go
so the correct answer is King E5 or King
F5
and this is a very worthwhile position
to know if H4
then King E4 and King F3 leads to a
position we've already seen
if King takes H3 it seems like White's
King isn't able to reach F3 in time but
that's an illusion white plays King F4
sear this position into your memory
remember this one it's worthwhile this
is a draw because black cannot do two
things at once right black wants to play
H4 and King G2 both but you can't play
them at the same time and if you play H4
you allow King F3 if you play King G2
then the distance between the king and
the pawn grows too large and white is
able to pick the pawn off with his own
king with a move King G5 and these lines
of course are very difficult to
calculate in your head especially if
you've forced yourself to calculate
without moving the pieces
but that's just what you got to deal
with in Pawn end game so what is this a
draw well as it turns out it is not a
drop
and here we have to turn to one of the
tips that I shared if your king
dominates its counterpart apply PPP push
your perspective passer before
eliminating your opponent's pots in
potent games you can reverse the order
of the stuff that you do if you
need to take your opponent's pawns and
then push your own Pawn you should often
consider what happens if you push your
Pawn first and only then take your
opponent's pawns you might assume that
well that this is commutative like oh if
you do the one thing it's going to be
the same that's not how chess works and
the reason that's not how chess works is
because that's not how King placement
works right if you keep your King on a
certain Square you might disallow or for
you might stop your opponent from making
the moves that he otherwise would have
been able to make and this is a great
illustration of that the winning move
the only winning move is H5 and after
King takes F7 the only winning move
again not King takes F4 but rather H4
you push the perspective Passer First
you get that out of the way and what you
can see is that the kings are in
opposition why is that important well
that's important because it prevents
white from heading back to the sixth
rank white in effect just has to waste a
move by playing King E7 and now black
takes on F4 and black has gained the
tempo pushing the spot up to H4 and
doing one of the tasks that black was
supposed to do in one of the drawn
position right we were discussing the
black has two things he wants to do and
only one move to do them here all black
needs to do is take on H3 and that is a
task black can succeed with in time King
F6 King G3 and white is not in time we
had this exact position but the Pod was
on H5 now it's on H4 and black wins
tempo for Tempo with the move King G2
and on the next move the red carpet is
unrolled and black promotes promotes the
h-man
so this one is is really just a
brilliant brilliant illustration of so
many different concepts you start with
the move F5 inducing weaknesses in
White's uh Pawn Camp you don't
automatically move your king to where
the enemy pawns are you realize that you
can use your pawns as a weapon
especially if you have doubled pawns
there's a nice sort of mini application
of waiting moves that is if white takes
and then plays F6 we we go for the
What's called the trebuchet position I
want to thank people in the chat in the
comments uh for for telling me that this
the situation with the uh with the Kings
on G6 and E7 like this is called a
trebuchet and just in general the
comments have been phenomenal so just a
huge shout out to everybody who's
engaging with these videos and leaving
these unbelievable generous comments uh
it warms my heart and it that's why I'm
so motivated to do these videos so I
wasn't planning to gush like halfway
through the video but really thank you
and and thank you for enlightening me on
uh certain things that I still have yet
to learn I have plenty to learn upon
games though don't get me wrong
um
so so there's the waiting move uh idea
that white is only one and black has two
and uh there's also the notion of
pushing your perspective passer right
not rushing to take the pawn and F4
that's the overarching theme of this
game not rushing to capture pawns but
oftentimes moving your own perspective
Passer First beforehand and keeping the
kings in opposition brilliant win by
lash Porter she found all of this and he
won in convincing fashion last really
quick thing if white plays King D7 here
and doesn't take on F5 then that makes
things easy King E4 King E7 and now F
takes G4 H takes G4 King takes F4 this
is pretty easy to establish here look at
how the H Pawn is like covering the G6
square and the path to promotion is
clear okay on we go to our final and
perhaps most exciting example I see that
we are about 40 moves up 40 moves into
the video 40 minutes into the video
that's perfect time that's exactly how I
had planned it so hopefully the pace has
not been too frenetic and if it has
remember that you can download these
Solutions uh database in the description
and you can uh you know view it at your
at your leisure oh I think I might have
cut off part of the oh I think I just
scrolled down like this
and now let's move this back up there's
going to be a lot to get through in this
example
I want to cut off part of the camera
which is probably a good thing anyway
because of the quality so you can see
that there are a ton of themes attended
to this example this is another simul
game but it's no longer Jose capoba
block at this time uh it's Vasily Smith
on the white side of the game and Mike
dicelin on the black side I would
imagine rated somewhere around Master
Level he was not rated at the time this
game was played and um yeah these people
playing symbols are tough we saw a
couple Blanca going down in flames now
we see Smith's love not quite going down
in flames but failing to spot a
brilliant win in this position that's in
front of you and yes white is in check
the question is obviously how should
white react to the Czech Black's last
move was F6 takes G5 check okay so if
you haven't seen any of the Pod end game
videos then the most natural reaction uh
to someone for someone who's not
experienced in panings would be well
what kind of psycho would not take the
pawn on G5 that's a dumb question
obviously the first move this game takes
you five why are you asking me that well
if you have watched the videos carefully
and as a more experienced student of
Pawn end games you will be able to
inform that person that wait a second in
pod end games it's often about whose
move it is moreover oftentimes the side
that has the move has a disadvantage
that is known as zuzvong and zuzvong is
a ridiculously common Concept in Pawn
games in fact there's no other type of
end game where zougsong is as ubiquitous
and as important of a weapon as in pawn
and game so getting the same position
with the other side to move is often the
path to victory that is precisely what
Smith love playing a similar playing on
a lot of boards failed to appreciate he
grabs on G5 and Mike Dyson is able to
draw the game after he takes D4
now again we have a situation that
should be familiar to you where both
kings are kind of vying for position on
the king side and neither King wants to
move whites King most certainly does not
want to move back black skin most
certainly does not want to move back and
allow White's King to step forward and
so we turn to the waiting moves we play
The Waiting move game who has more
waiting boosts well the problem is that
white has to start first
white has two waiting moves and so does
black and so the waiting moves cancel
each other out A3 you know the drill A6
not A5 not A5 because after A4 white
wins and here a beautiful application of
mowing the lawn King G6 King f8 how does
white clear the path to the weak B6 Pawn
well you already know the drill white
plays F6 trading off the final blade of
grass on the king side takes takes and
white just walks over and wins the B6
Pawn notice that there is no
breakthrough here because there's a c
Pawn that's guarding uh the B5 square
and again white benefits from having
doubled C plots
so instead diceland correctly plays A6
A4 only now black plays A5 and white is
the one in zugs Von he has to drop the
king back to G4 and uh black can draw
this in a variety of ways as it turns
out even King F6 draws I mean here after
King F4 it may seem like white as in
Black isn't suicide but actually that's
he's not King E7 white plays King E5
congrats you have the opposition but
remember opposition is not a Panacea
black slides over to F7 and we're at a
dead end because if we head for D6 we
lose the F bottom black promotes uh in a
way too early black winds and white
cannot make any progress again in this
case it doesn't even matter who has the
opposition black can go wherever the
heck he wants
um except F7 this is what you want to
avoid because here white gets the G6 all
you want to avoid is the corresponding
squares G5 and F7 that is you want to
make sure that you step onto F7 only
when white steps onto G5 those are the
only mine squares as long as you avoid
F7
um until white thing is on G5 are good
so that's how the game ended uh the game
ended in a draw
now when you're looking at these lines
the first thing that should by now come
to mind is well let's get the same
position with black to move let's get
black to be the one to exhaust his
waiting moves first and that is why you
should come up with the brilliant move
King G4 I love this move this is just y
pawn and games are so beautiful this is
the only winning move okay King H5 is
also winning but it's exactly the same
thing
so the point is that after e takes D4
King takes G5 it is now black to play
and if we go through the same line A6 A3
A5 A4 it's now black to move the Kings
stand on the corresponding squares and
black loses to King F6 King G6 King f8
and G6 and then F6 we we know the drill
but that's not the end of the story and
it's very important when you're
assessing winning moves to really
exhaustively assess all of your
opponent's possible podmost if you look
at this position carefully you'll notice
that black also has the move B5 and this
is actually a really really annoying
move because after the trade
after the trade it turns out that white
is all of a sudden out of waiting moves
right why does the one who has exhausted
his final waiting move and we kind of
know the drill that Kings just start
dancing around the F5 and G7 pawns
except this is where the second critical
concept that this game comes in anytime
there is a transformation of the pawn
structure you have to sort of reassess
the situation because in trading a pair
of Pawns your opponent may have
inadvertently or unwittingly weakened
his or her Pawn structure on the side of
the board where the trade occurred so
that may have blazed new trails or new
Pathways for your king if that is
precisely what happens here
in this situation right black spots are
all defending each other but once B5 is
played we saw an example like this in
the previous video the pod on C5 is
suddenly a huge weakness and white can
use this fact to initiate a advantageous
Pawn race
but it's important to do it in a very
particular way there are some mind
squares in particular F4 and F6 are
actually corresponding squares if you
play King F4 and you rush toward D5 you
forfeit the win black plays King F6
now you might say well I go King E4 and
I push Black's King back but except you
don't black goes to G5 and keeps himself
anchored anchored to the F5 Pawn this is
where I remind you that shouldering is
only good with respect to the other
plots Right congratulations here you
have shouldered black skin technically
but black skin remains pegged to the F5
Pawn disallowing white from moving the
king to D5 you can convince yourself of
this but the pawn race is losing for
white by the way nice application of a
pawn race rule in fact of two Pawn race
rules here this is why I chose these
examples you have these random lines
where you just incidentally see other
rules being applied so the first rule
you have to remember is to use your king
to block your opponent's king from
stopping your pawns that's why G4 would
be a terrible move due to King E3 you
have to play King F4 the other rule is
to identify the checking zone of both
pawns that will help you see if a pawn
happens to promote with check which can
change the outcome of Pawn race that is
precisely was that what happens here
white rushes the plot to C4 G4 C5 G3
actually y can play CB and you might say
hey White's going to promote the check
but black promotes first and
the white king happens to be in the
checking zone of black screen black
promotes with check and then easily
stops white spawns just an amazing line
where white only loses by the skin of
his teeth but still loses and if white
goes F6 and tries to eliminate the pawns
then again white loses because Black's
King is a lot closer to the C2 Pawn in
Black's pawns which is better positioned
uh to benefit in the ensuing uh Pawn
race you can convince yourself of this
on your own so amazingly the natural
King F4 steps onto a mind Square you
have to go through G4 you have to once
again perform triangulation if black
steps onto F6 then white plays King F4
putting black and zoukzone black now
does have to step back and wide steps
forward to E5 if black plays C4 then
it's really easy you take and you play
A4 and then you promote the a pawn the
thing is close enough to to Black spawns
you might notice the uh easy
breakthrough but white has King E3 and
the pawn is Comfortably stopped so so
here Black is Black is going to say well
I'm not stepping onto F6 I'm also going
to start dancing but this is the kind of
scenario that we saw in the Beret of
Polgar game where what what white has to
do is just circumvent the F4 square
right white plays King F3
triangulation King F7 black just has to
toggle between these two squares black
plays King D6 then zuzvong arrives even
faster white plays King E4 and here the
shouldering actually works because black
is getting shouldered with respect to
these pawns and these pawns are
incredibly vulnerable King B6 you can
actually go either King D5 or even King
E6 and King F7 and here white wins the
race uh so
this doesn't work black has to go King
F7 and now you go through E4 and this is
the Brilliance of White's strategy black
has a losing ultimatum if black doesn't
play King F6 and black plays King E7
then we infiltrate to D5 we will examine
the scenario in a second
if black plays King F6 then we double
back to F4 hitting our Target position
with black to move and finally black is
in zuk's one and finally we get access
to Black's Queen side pawns and even
this is not the end of the story King
F16 takes C5 you have to evaluate the
pawn race after King takes F5 the
amazing thing is that the white king
captures on D4
and you might say well wait a second
didn't we just have this position didn't
we determine that black is winning no no
no we had this position with black to
move and with black sorry we have this
position with a pawn already on G5 that
extra Tempo results in a win four uh for
black but with white move you have the
mirror image on the other side black
skin is now in the checking zone of the
seaport pod if black plays G5 then after
CB it is no longer black who promotes
with check it is white who promotes his
chat now you might say but wait a second
black is going to take on C4 first and
after dcg5 the white Pawn uh the black
king is no longer in the checking zone
of White's Pawn but here you perform a
technique that we also covered in the
pawn race video you slide your king back
to D3 what you're doing is you're
forcing black skank further and further
into uh the board what does this move do
well let's think about what this move
does well what this move does is it puts
the king in opposition to White's King
and now you have to reassess the pawn
race it also takes the white king away
from the checking zone of the black pawn
which means that now the pawns promote
simultaneously and it's now white to
move and by now you should be totally
primed to look for ways to engage a
favorable Queen trade you should
identify the scenario from 10 miles away
if you're black so you should try not to
touch this with a 10 foot hole because
after being F5 and queen G5 you know the
drill by now so very well you trade
queens and we have exactly one pass Pawn
left in that past spawn decides the game
this is just a mind-blowing line to me
because it's just how many Concepts it
illustrates in one and after BBC DC G5
King D3 if black tries to go the other
way it is worth remembering that
two pawns that are on adjacent files are
self-sufficient I talked about this in
the pawn past Pawn video what you want
to do here is play A4
and if black goes after one Pawn you
push the other one again if you're not
familiar with this consult that video
re-watch it if black goes around and
says now let me get to the A5 fund the
moment the king reaches B7 white plays
C5 and whichever way black goes white
pushes the respective other pawn and
black will never be able to take one of
the pawns without allowing the other one
to promote in the meantime white is just
going to step up take the Jeep one and
then walk the king over to assist these
two Heroes on on the CNA file so we need
to rewind all the way back here all the
way back just just to recap what we just
did in this position
so actually let's go back to the start
it all started with us understanding
that we need to get this position with
black to move because we need black to
start exhausting his waiting moves first
so we force black to play A6 and if
black plays A5 then it's all very easy
we mow the law and we play F6 and we get
to the B Pawn right that's
straightforward but black can play the
move B5 now we don't forget that when
pawns are traded you have to reassess
the pawn structure you have actually
induced the weakness that weakness is C5
but the way you want to approach that
weakness is not by stepping onto a line
square and allowing Black's King to
reach the king side clinging to the F
button you want to triangular way to go
King G3 then King F3 and you can call
this triangulation but in a sense this
is almost like circumventing a mind
Square this is a fundamentally different
concept where you're still reaching your
destination you're just not driving onto
the you know there's a road a bunch of
cops on there there's a closed Road just
not driving onto that road right you're
avoiding the 101 freeway in San
Francisco
fortunately there's no way to avoid it I
hate the 101 freeway
um
so you're just avoiding the Mind Square
cooking E4 and as soon as black steps up
to his corresponding Square we slide
back to F4 inducing the target position
the zigzvonk and then it's still not the
end of the story in the pawn race in the
pawn Race White uses a bunch of
techniques to get Black's King onto the
maximally vulnerable uh position after
G5 C4 flexing is in the checking Zone
and after bcdc Black's King is dragged
back to F3 using the rule that says you
should help your uh you should help it
upon Race by dragging your opponent's
king onto the least desirable Square by
threatening to stop your opponent's Pawn
with your own King and then you use what
we started with these Concepts they've
come full circle remember the capablanca
game we had a very similar idea there
you had to assess an entirely new pod
end game here it's much easier because
you have a past a pawn house Miss love
didn't find this in a simul game I do
not know
I'm kidding of course and that ladies
and gentlemen concludes our Whirlwind
tour of these five exercises these are
once again this is the first set there
will be a second video with five more
exercises and those will cover the
themes uh that we have not touched upon
as frequently today now remember this
isn't about oh I'm giving equal coverage
to every single concept there will be
Concepts that we don't like necessarily
directly talk about while there are
other Concepts like Pawn races that I'm
talking about very frequently and that
is because of how important uh I think
they are and hopefully you found the
exercise is stimulating hopefully you
found them somewhat interesting and I
just want to repeat what I started with
which is that even if you decided not to
solve these exercises or if you tried to
solve them but couldn't that doesn't
mean that you know that you sucker that
you didn't appreciate the videos uh
these were supposed to be incredibly
challenging and stimulating and these
were supposed to further your
understanding rather than undermine it
so you know don't worry don't be too
harsh on yourself but feel free to
consult the solutions PGN if you want to
review stuff and you want to revisit all
of these beautiful variations and on
that note ladies and gentlemen uh I hope
you have found the audio to be tolerable
thank you so much for watching for all
of the super wholesome feedback and I
will see you in the next puzzle solving
video
[Music]